all right great so I observe it I'm
going to tell you about this brand new
library that was literally just released
yesterday you can find it here and
github and what enables you to do is to
add scalable data dependencies to Python
projects all right so before I tell you
a bit more about the library and tell
you a bit more about the motivation like
why why did I end up making this so I
started my career like in data science
and machine learning about nine years
ago and I used to manage my data
manually syncing files uploading
downloading but then there was initially
that work well but then there was some
disasters some files were overwritten
months of work lost and so on so then I
thought well you know this is terrible
we should be doing something much better
so then I said well I'm already using it
to manage all of my code so why don't I
use get to also manage all my data so
forget there's this thing called git LFS
it enables you to efficiently store all
of your data in get and again that
worked fine for a while but then one
second started working working in a team
and so on what I found is that it just
like over time that imposter II would
blow it because everybody would add all
of their files in and and then
eventually you'll have this kind of you
want to check out the latest commit and
it takes like three hours to pull all
these like ten gigabytes of files so
that didn't scale either and I was
sufficiently annoyed with this whole
thing to say well actually we need a new
solution and actually kind of sit down
and try to write it and that's kind of
how lazy data was born and the idea is
essentially we want to store our
references to files and get so that so
we still get this kind of benefit of
being able to version everything but
then we don't want to pull the data
automatically we want to be able to kind
of programmatically lazy load it
whenever we need it so that enables us
to treat our storage back in this kind
of a black hole so you just put
everything there and you just get files
as you need them and when you need them
so hopefully they're so far this is
scaled but we'll see all right so you do
pip pip install lazy data so what
happens next so
a simple script the only thing you need
to do is really to that two lines of
code so obviously the import and then
the second line of code is this track so
what track does is just it's just going
to start tracking this this data file
that you give it as a parameter so when
I run Python my script PI that's going
to then say well I'm tracking a new file
so what does it mean that I'm tracking a
new file well we're going to take this
file we're going to hard link it to a
local cache that means we're just going
to make like an efficient copy of it and
we're going to calculate the hash of it
or sha-256 we're going and we're going
to add it to this lazy data dot yml file
so this lazy data why am i file
essentially has all of your files that
you currently have that are kind of
currently linked to your project your to
your to get repository and in this in
this case I just have one one file but I
could have many and this is a file that
you would keep and get so this is kind
of what assures that like at this
specific gif commit I was using this
specific file alright so and you're
pretty much done
you've not versioned all of your kind of
stuff internally within your within your
computer within your project now of
course we want to share this so are we
going to add a remote in this case I'm
going to choose s3 and I'm going to do
lays data push so that's just going to
take all the stuff I have locally cached
and just push it to s3 and then my
collaborators we can pull the code there
with the code they'll get this lazy data
but yml and they can download individual
files if they want to or directories or
whatever but they can also just say byte
in my script PI and what this is going
to do is it's going to run that same
script and what and when again we get
that track command that's now going to
check it's going to see that we have a
file that we are tracking but it's not
present in the local copy as you going
to say okay I know where to find this
file because I know the remote is I know
where the hash is I'm just going to go
and download it so essentially if you're
just kind of rerunning someone else's
scripts or just kind of going someone
else's notebook you can just use it
essentially it works and that's pretty
much it
you now have a Python project with data
dependencies obviously this is a
completely new project so I think a lot
more is
going to be coming soon because you have
this programmatic access there's lots of
interesting stuff you can do so you can
like add dependencies to notebooks to
classes to Buyten projects I mean
Brighton packages and yeah that's pretty
much it thanks very much check it out
[Applause]